over the course of the last week or so
twitch streamer ludwig
has built a functional casino
in minecraft as if minecraft wasn't
already addictive enough
ludwig is blowing up on twitch right now
and he might just be
the next king of just chatting
all right guys it's that time of year
again the score esports award
is back on december 11th and this year
we're doing it live make sure you tune
in while we talk about what was a
crazy year in esports and hand out some
pretty cool awards
see you there all right so if you're not
a twitch head and you don't know who
ludwig is
he's likely the fastest growing just
chatting streamer on the planet right
now
he got a start in the smash scene both
competing and commentating
and since then he's become one of these
people that
explode on twitch just sitting in front
of a camera and being entertaining
doing whatever among us with xqc
look i don't have to play with him this
is what will happen yo i think it's xqc
uh there's somebody who killed in the
electric room he was the last one there
and it felt like he just
off you think like mizkiff hassan
xqc to some extent sodapoppin you get
the drift
mostly he's just another react andy but
he's actually like good at it a little
less screaming at the top of his lungs
and a little more actual content so the
reason
this is so funny it it's because when
you
sometimes there's this glitch where it
if you sub for three months it's
he talks politics reacts to clips opens
pokemon cards gambles
and is usually at least good for one
life lesson per stream
feed a man of fish he's full for a day
teach a man to fish and you can steal
from him next week and recently
his channel is [ __ ] blowing up on
twitch
we're talking going from averaging 10k
viewers to 20k
viewers in just one month it's pretty
unprecedented on twitch and the reason
for that
is at least some part related to the
fact that he built a
functioning blackjack casino in the
offline tv minecraft server i can't make
this [ __ ] up guys
gamble responsibly one diamond equals
one dollar me
i go all out one stack of diamond
when you're done you hit done it'll
count your money up
and put it all onto a card 64 bucks
sounds good to me
now you got it on your card walk over to
the blackjack table
drop it over the curtain and then you
can start playing some blackjack
let's go all in that's a 19.
stand the dealer will have a seven we
win one full stack of diamond
when you run out of money you hit quit
now one thing that you need to know
about ludwig that prompted this
massive minecraft construction project
is that he loves to gamble
boys what's up today we're playing a bit
of poker
oh you're on a roll with this [ __ ]
and i've never beaten anyone noteworthy
streamers from the offline tv content
house come to his casino buy diamonds
and
gamble for in-game currency right now
you can only play blackjack
but soon according to ludwig you'll be
able to play roulette too
on the server ludwig also owns a diamond
loan
agency where you can get 64 diamonds
at an interest rate of three diamonds
per day which is the most gambling [ __ ]
i have
ever heard in my life one can only
wonder what happens when you don't pay
where's the money lebowski over the
course of the past few weeks ludwig has
been surging on twitch
on the back of this casino project with
otv and streaming to like 30
000 people a day now putting aside how
impressive this casino thing is for a
second
i do think ludwig is benefiting from a
streaming wide
trend right now with the popularity of
fall guys and now among
us we have seriously seen some of these
just chatting style
channels truly pop off over the last six
months
names like valkyrie hassan moist
critical
corpse disguised toast in addition to
ludwig
have really found a way to capitalize on
the popularity of among us
and mix that with their personality
content and people
really [ __ ] like it in fact over the
course of the last year
just chatting has been the most watched
category
on all of twitch compared to the prior
year it grew
149 percent
turns out all anybody really wanted on
twitch was
someone to sit on the other side of the
monitor and
[Music]
talk to him wait on a more serious note
though
ludwig is doing this [ __ ] pretty
differently it's no secret that
while just chatting has grown a ton over
the last few years
it's usually been led by people who act
like lunatics
on stream there really was never much of
a rhyme or reason
to what xqc or mischief or sodapopping
were doing in front of a camera but ludd
seems to bring
a little bit more of a refined product
to the table
every clip that i see of this guy makes
me [ __ ] jealous
and he's been on lsf a lot i just can't
[ __ ] get over it
now i think the whole like small
streamer thing
it can be good but at the i'm jealous
yeah it's envious asmin jealousy is when
you are afraid of losing something you
have from someone or something envy is
when you want something that you don't
have
okay higher production value a
consistent streaming schedule
sometimes even segmented content and a
strong
vod presence on youtube and he's not
afraid to tell you
how lazy he thinks other streamers could
be streamers
in slime has said this before are like
dumb rich
babies they complain a lot they get
filthy amounts of money and they are
lazy as all hell he's even running some
of his own events
like the smash tournament he ran a few
weeks ago after that whole
free melee fiasco with ludwig we get the
combination
of somebody willing to spend 235
000 to open pokemon cards on stream
oh let's go
but is also willing to spend two days
straight streaming the us election
to a high of more than 40 000 viewers
over the past year we've really seen
whatever wall existed between streamer
and viewer
break down to the point where it's
virtually non-existent
and ludwig is the embodiment of that
he's not afraid to talk about the latest
drama that everyone wants to hear about
uh something that fed meister wrote a
while ago got leaked
and i didn't think that this would come
back to me but it did
and so i have to admit i leaked the
document because pokeman's last retweet
was about pokemon week but he also goes
pretty deep
on the streamer lifestyle what people
like him get paid
and what he wants to see change in the
world of streaming don't say that's one
stream for you schla i don't make 30 000
per stream that'd be pathetic it's like
half a stream
what am i poor he truly is the closest
thing we have to a full window inside
the world of streaming and having him be
the place to go to learn about politics
smash pokemon cards and now gambling in
minecraft
has cemented his spot among some of the
biggest streamers in the world
i'm telling you this guy could be the
next king of twitch
i don't know about you people out there
in youtube land but right now
in canada we're on lockdown number two
and i'm running out of things to do it
might be time it might be time to play a
[ __ ] video game you know what i'm
saying
i'm a ludwig fan because it's it's good
to finally it's like a song right like
it's good to finally have
like streamers that are like personality
focused because i think that content's
cool
but like are not like screaming
all the time
like that's the core tenet of this video
it's like
twitch streamer that isn't screaming
merry christmas you filthy animals